(upbeat orchestral music)
- [Jurgen] People enjoy mayhem,
especially when it
happens to other people.
There's definitely a
factor of schadenfreude
in watching something go terribly wrong
to someone else.
- [Narrator] You're in a U-Haul.
You're about to start your
first semester at Duke,
and driving down the
road you see this sign.
And another sign.
You pay no attention,
and then this sign lights up,
and then disaster strikes.
You're about to get
your 15 minutes of fame
all thanks to this man.
- [Jurgen] Hi, I'm Jurgen Henn.
- [Narrator] And he's
infamous in these parts.
Right, Jurgen?
- One can say that yes, I am,
known as the 11 foot
8 guy around here.
- [Narrator] Jurgen and his
wife started 11foot8.com,
which is what exactly?
- 11 Foot 8 website records
all the truck crashes
that happen here at the
11 foot 8 bridge.
It's really all it is. (laughs)
Eight years ago I set up a
camera outside my office here,
and started recording the traffic
that goes under the
railroad trestle behind me.
Within a few weeks, I recorded
a truck crashing into the railroad bridge.
- [Narrator] Since installing the camera,
Jurgen has uploaded video of
113 crashes at the bridge,
and amassed over 10 million views.
Most bridges in the state
have a 15 foot clearance.
The 11 foot 8 bridge, however,
was built 100 years ago,
hence the lower height.
And now thanks to Jurgen,
these crashes have a dedicated following.
- Our fans are really intensely
interested in these crashes,
and they love to buy souvenirs,
little piece of crash art.
- [Narrator] Uh, what's crash art?
- The crash art are bent,
mangled pieces of aluminum
that usually form the frame of the truck.
And the impact crushes that aluminum
and kind of twists it
in interesting shapes.
People will buy the
crash art, they love it.
For some of them it's almost like
owning a piece of the Berlin Wall.
- [Narrator] Why doesn't the
town just raise the trestle
or lower the road?
- [Jurgen] From the perspective
of the city and the state DOT,
the low clearance is clearly marked,
and it's up to the driver
to decide their next move.
Structural changes at this intersection
would be extremely costly.
- [Narrator] Well at least
we have these awesome videos.
Right?
- I get no satisfaction
out of seeing a new crash.
If we found an actual solution
to prevent this tomorrow,
I'd be all over it, I love it.